hallo mein name ist luca und ich
beantworte heute fragen was soll der
scheiß
keine ahnung kann es sein dass du dumm
bist ich glaube ja ist jude deine
freundin hast du die anderen phobie ich
habe keine ahnung was das sein soll aber
ich glaube auch er nein stell dir vor
ich wäre ein eskimo am nordpol und du
müsstest mir einen kühlschrank verkaufen
wie würdest du versuchen mich zu
überzeugen die ich würde sagen wenn du
den kühlschrank nicht kaufsüchtig wann
kommt mal wieder ein instagram live
stream heute um 20 uhr dienstag ran
kennst du die schami ziege nein
ok jetzt schon würdest du gerne mal für
einen tag oder länger ein mädchen sein
diesmal die kinder und die frau schöne
grüße an die kinder und die frau was
würdest du machen wenn youtube gesperrt
wird ich würde vermutlich keine
youtube-videos mehr machen letzte
benutzte unterhose
die hier kommst du eigentlich deine
faust den mund
hast du eigentlich freunde auch eher
negativ hast du einen plan oder schaust
du wie es kommt ich habe eigentlich
schon plan würde ich sagen was war das
peinlichste was sie jeden der schule
passiert ist ich bin mal gegen die
glastür gerannt
sorry wieso kannst du nicht geben ich
kann doch gehen wie viele stunden am tag
schläfst du normalerweise so sechs bis
sieben würde ich sagen welchen filter
benutzt auf all deinen fotos freunde von
mir bearbeiten meine fotos also ich habe
keine ahnung davon vogel oder pinguin
definitiv pinguin heißt sand sand weil
er zwischen see und land liegt
das ist eine sehr gute theorie in wie
vielen ländern warst du schon
in zwölf halo kwadrat haus des geldes
gesucht und meine frage ist jetzt
welcher charakter wärst du gerne schwer
eigentlich gerne rio
findest du youtube deutschland hat sich
ins negative verändert
nie würde ich jetzt nicht direkt sagen
die findest du denn viele ich mag
delfino bist du der echte akkurat ja ok
rom oder soja ok abwehr ist momentan die
wichtigste person in seinem leben also
ich würde sagen die wichtigsten personen
in meinem leben ist meine familie ich
wollte dich fragen ist es schwer
nachzudenken was für ein video mache ich
heute beziehungsweise morgen wenn du
einen ablaufplan hast es ist eigentlich
nicht so schwer hast du eigentlich auch
ein idol meiner idole sind kate winslet
und david dobrick hattest du schon mal
eine grüne hose anhöhe aber ich habe
gerade ein grünes t shirt an warum so
lange keine videos mit max mehr weil max
am studieren ist hatte ich das video
beginnen
du bist mittendrin würdest du den
nächsten monat und youtube aufhören auf
keinen fall wie stehst du zur
schlachtung von ameisen im kopf der
eleganten auftritte des fahrgast eines
staubsaugers des lebens
haben
warum es polaroid so poetisch schönes
wort
bis heute fragen in deiner ins tableau
steht das hotel ist zeigt doch mal was
du kannst du stehst du zu dem thema
homosexualität ist was komplett normales
finde ich hat ein linker kleiner zeh
einen namen
wann kommt das motto one gegen ninja ich
will nicht dass er anfängt zu weinen
deswegen lasse ich das lieber könntest
du mal wieder ein minecraft projekt
machen sowie das megaprojekt ich denke
ja nicht weil das ja ein riesiges
projekt habe ich werde bestimmt
demnächst mal wieder minecraft hochladen
warum bist du so hässlich
entschuldigung an der stelle würde das
heutige jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren ich wollte
einfach mal so ganz knapp hintereinander
fragen beantworten wenn es euch gefallen
hat und jetzt nochmal sehen wollt dann
lasst mal gern ein leica schreibt
weitere fragen und in die kommentare die
ich dann immer dass wir das nächste mal
beantworten und jetzt würde ich
eigentlich nur noch sagen